hey moviegoers my name is Ryan writes
and I'm Jerry and I'm Erin welcome to
raisins to see will we give you reasons
to see and maybe not to see meaning gain
so let's work out you just can't kidnap
a guy and take his things that's so
illegal sure we can Victor Kershaw is a
criminal prick who deserves bad stuff to
have before we go through with this
nobody gets hurt right we grab
we get my protein shake since today we
got a buddy on the show Aaron on Aaron
is easy
he's also another movie buff and so yeah
he's got a whey protein with us today
you know what you know lately and if
you've seen it our review of spring
breakers you'll see the guy has lost
some weight and built on some muscle you
see him right over here so I'm excited
to have him on the show reason to see
number one Dwayne
not the rock Johnson we're doing a
chopped up north are you fixed for a job
no she's gonna be the rock forever movie
where he's like his whole characters
like look how [ __ ] Jack - this guy is
of course he had the rock but as far as
he goes in this movie I said we did GI
Joe and I said it when we did snitch and
by far this is to me his best
performance he's ever done yeah I [ __ ]
loved him in this movie he's my favorite
actor in the film and Wow the guy has so
much improved starts as an ex-con that's
like really hopped up on the Jesus juice
his speech patterns like his mannerisms
they all feel like a guy that's like
really desperately trying to stay on
this like very narrowly straight in
there yeah he's a recovering coke addict
and you know you can actually feel his
internal struggle but you know he's also
having a lot of fun with the role while
bringing that emotional death he's funny
in it a lot of the time he's the most
likable one out of all of them is that
is the one you you can get behind the
most people I I know people that are
really deeply devout and really deeply
religious like he I believe this guy
like hung around in the church and just
sort of got into the vibe of those kinds
of people and just like he really
communicates that really well it feels
like a real character yeah
real character in a very over-the-top
movie here's a deal little fella I'm
gonna headbutt you knock you out do
something bad
they got my toe you can see the bone
he's rock solid reason to see number two
Mark Wahlberg
my name is Daniel Lugo and I believe in
fitness Marky Mark is like [ __ ]
bulked up in this guy workout you are
Adrienne even though he's the lead
apathy of the group I was more
impressive dwayne johnson but rihanna
this Mark Wahlberg does a solid solid
job he's got a great body
well a little homo he anchors the trio
well and he brings you know a good
presence to everything and you don't
like him at all but you're doing him and
you are fascinated by I gotta disagree I
did like him like that's what that was
that was something I appreciated about
the characters in this film was it's a
question amongst the audience of you
either like them where you don't like
them and it's a challenge for the
audience to like them or not and Mark
Wahlberg was especially a challenge is
he's the baddest one out of them oh yeah
pains it's gonna save your life just
cells remember when hurts and that's
where they get strong
it's called pain and game rush you're
gonna man up you better cause right now
your sister stronger than you give me
your hand get up what are you looking at
you little chubby broad don't eyeball me
boy I see your mother driving up no
Street looking at me how do you step
forth about a weekend I think Mark
Wahlberg is like his character Daniel
Lugo is fascinating because he very much
sucks you in like he believes in you
like when he says at the very beginning
it's like my name is Daniel Lugo and I
believe in fitness like you get this guy
has a dog mutt he has a doctrine he has
like these things that he sticks to in
these guns I used takes two really tough
lis
he's an unlikable character but at the
same time you can kind of sympathize
women because he believes so hard and
what he's doing I guess it's like you
know I didn't hate him by an Easter Day
night I've met a lot of people who are
like Mark Wahlberg who you know have
these huge aspirations these huge dreams
but are trying to find the shortcuts to
life all the time
he's like a really conniving [ __ ] yes
so caught up in these philosophies these
motive things
their dreams but when it comes to taking
action it's like they suck at it is that
a question I'm a doer
what is this Valentine's Day say it like
you want to hunt it skin it and not his
head on your wall I'm a door
he's really he's really obsessed and
really like fallen hook line and sinker
for the whole cult of success yeah yeah
he's a compulsive liar and no matter
what he's already he's always got some
[ __ ] story and you you get that this
guy believes every [ __ ] story they
suppose I'm the universe this guy just
lives like in a fantasy land in his mind
you know and it's you can really you can
feel all that Mark Wahlberg brings that
you know they like the tagline for this
movie is their American Dream is bigger
than yours and I think that really
defines Mark Wahlberg characters so well
you you really say how many succeeded
there are a lot of thuggy nights you
could almost say that they almost were
living like rock stars you see number
three anthony mackie yeah are you
currently using steroids
I think they messed me up took a lot of
balls to come in here
what like Raisinets at least Joe's a
chocolate-covered Raisinets
oh sorry you know what man I like that
guy and I'm happy to see him doing some
more comedic stuff yeah yeah I mean he
plays the third wheel of this group like
he's not on most of the posters so he's
not the he's not that famous yeah he's
not but it's like yeah he's he is up he
is an equal part of the trip and he's
part of the Sun gym gang yeah yeah when
you watch the movie is an equal part of
the group he's just not as part of the
trailer as much as you know Dwayne
Johnson and Mark Wahlberg are you kind
of feel bad for him out of the three of
them he has the Leafs going for him he's
the smallest he's the dumbest he's the
most cowardly the only thing the least
conviction out of the whole group he's
like the most he's the biggest wannabe
he's the biggest follower you know yeah
there's no it's there's something about
him that seems like he might have been
completely influenced and manipulated by
Mark Wahlberg character you want to
change right are you kind of changed in
that fanny pack is that what you want
ones last time you paid to rent one he
was doing when's the last time you took
one of those plump [ __ ] out to dinner
and get this wet the morning desert you
love those big [ __ ] they love to eat
it's okay that's important this big bro
it's got to stop man you know and some
people are getting a little upset that
this movie is a dark comedy and they're
portraying these characters in a comedic
light but it's like well these guys are
a joke you know like but they seal off
some crazy [ __ ] but they're at the end
of the day they're joke but I didn't
think it cross the line for me at least
because it was like there was never a
time where I was actually rooting for
them to succeed yeah yeah you guys are
all idiots and the movie knows it and
but they all play it in a way where you
can still enjoy life yeah because for
most of the time I found the characters
to be that you know with honesty I was
really engrossed because of the
performances because they actually make
these people understandable not that you
do up in Norway
but you get them you do understand them
at the end of the day you can kind of
sympathize with them and that you
understand their motives and where
they're coming from and because they're
morons yeah you can kind of feel bad for
them yeah
he was right here
I told you to check the license this
could have gone very wrong with a weird
past because you've got to be able to
like watching unlikable characters yeah
they do succeed with that and they
walked a really dangerous line by taking
real guys that you know I mean I mean
like Daniel Lugo in real life is still
alive the loved ones of the people who
were so horribly affected by these three
guys they're still alive they still bear
the scars of this and it's a dangerous
[ __ ] line to walk to like taking the
villain of this story make them your
protagonist but that's what that's
honestly what I really appreciated about
it was it's a such a challenging job and
I thought with the performances and the
way the characters were written it was
pulled off well reason I see number four
Tony Shalhoub I'm a self-made man I made
a lot of money maybe yourself ought to
spend some of it on a salad you know who
invented salad poor people
Tasha Loeb is gonna be playing a Jewish
guy forever this is a good job playing I
like the older he gets the more Jewish
guy rolls he's gonna get even though
he's like a Canadian Lebanese dude yeah
you know he's a great [ __ ] actor he's
a beer a Jewish guy yeah he has this
incredible ability to make you believe
the person right away and almost any
role he does he knows how to embody a
role and have fun with it at the same
time he makes it look easy and he's
flawless he's a natural man he's not a
very easy disposition and granted it's
like his character Kershaw is kind of
OneNote and it's kind of interesting
that you get I mean it explains how
these guys got away with so much he's
such a [ __ ] ass yeah that's like in
it's the only reason they go after this
guy he's rich and he's such an [ __ ]
yeah that's what I liked about it was
they kept the main characters worse than
their target they didn't you know it's
like yeah the guy's an ass you know a
weird way it's like they're more likable
than him but they're also worse though
they're sociopaths their personality is
more likable but you know the end of the
day Tony Shalhoub it these not do a
little call the girl like Tony Shalhoub
called the girl fat like made fun of you
kids acne and like yelled at them for
not working well it is doubt that is
deli Mark Wahlberg burgers people yeah
tortures that you know like most of
these movies would do some type of
Hollywood deceit where they would you
know make the bad guy more bad than them
so that way our characters are more
likable and I like the idea of
challenging the audience like that where
they don't make their target though
technically because the first half they
pretty much set up Tony Shalhoub like he
is the antagonist of the film yeah you
know essentially but they don't make him
worse than our main characters so it's
an exciting movie to watch where it's
like wow the main characters Ruby are
worse pretty much everyone in this plot
is very likable yeah and it's a miracle
that they're all fun to watch I got to
get a puppy
good it hurts I know it does that's it
get it to see number five Harris the Sun
gym gang has successfully acquired every
asset you had what happens now now I go
to work he's got kind of flat character
he's the guy that just sort of like all
right I guess I'll investigate this guy
telling me this crazy story about body
builders that kidnapped him and stole
his shed and then he becomes basically
our only good good guy antagonist what I
will say is like I agree that he is sort
of a flat character but I thought at
Harris what he brought to it you could
feel the guy's history you could feel
the guy's backstory you could tell it ed
Harris at the end of the day didn't go
all right he's a fly character who's
gonna half-ass this I think that's just
because ed Harris liked his face and his
voice look like they're made out of old
weather oh yeah I feel like there's an
emotional depth that he actually brought
to it cuz he made the guy he wouldn't
have been able to pull off everything
and make him feel a human if there
wasn't that level of death that was
brought to it yeah I mean you you want
all your characters to have depth you
want them all to be written that way but
he's also the character who he comes in
later on in the plot he's not on screen
a whole bunch like you know he does
mostly advanced the story but I really
enjoyed watching and Harris in that role
I thought he brought a lot of presents
to yeah he has one thing to do pretty
much and he's hired you know by Tony
Shalhoub to do it he's really enjoyable
to watch and he's a good foil for
everything's going on number six holy
[ __ ] Michael Bay yeah surprisingly you
know there's a thing about Michael Bay
where people are just not going to like
this movie simply because they know
Michael Bay directed that guy comes with
baggage just yeah I love it between you
and the screen everyone knows that
Michael Bay has an ego problem like he
has a temper problem but at the same
time that's why
he's the perfect director for this
because out of anyone to direct this
because this is this is a character
based movie that was surprising to me
it's very character-based not even the
explosions explosion and if anyone
understands these characters it's
probably Michael baby baby could really
get a is like the Michael Bay is like he
is any one of these guys before they
started lifting because he's got the ego
but he just doesn't have the gains for
it yeah most every shot Michael Bay can
get his hands on he tries to turn it
into the money shot
this sounds like this is that movie that
is about excess and it is about that
descent into madness and it is about
just everything being dialed up to 11 so
this is a movie that's got a story on
roids and Michael Bay is the guy to do a
movie on roids yeah and he was in my
opinion the perfect director for it
because it was it's such a you know I've
heard that this story that this
portrayal of these guys is as is pretty
accurate actually like everyone who
knows the story says like it does yeah
like this [ __ ] crazy and he manages
to bring it to make it into sort of a
dark comedy make it such an inner it's
kind of what I was watching it with all
the narration that goes on in it it was
kind of like watching if Michael Bay
suddenly got inspired by a good college
it's because it has a lot of similar
themes to it but it's like Michael Bay
status you know it is very visually
appealing but at the same time it's
character based so it's great to see a
true story done in a very unique fashion
yeah yeah it's not just trying to fill
time with when's the next big fight
scene we can hang out you're actually
you're watching a plot unfold there are
times where it goes go Michael Bay out
but it works though it bits no yeah it's
got every trick in the Michael Bay book
but but in a place where it's okay like
yeah it makes sense and it's not like
it's not so short on any kind of
substance that it's overloaded with
Michael Bay isms it's sort of a
different mix of both rather than being
emotionally moving
I found this film more interesting than
emotionally moving because I don't think
Michael Bay's in the business of kept my
interest the whole time money baby has
one feeling is shake this out a little
bit no like he succeeded and what he
wanted to do he made it a smaller film
that managed to be about people so
people are always saying he doesn't know
how to do movies about actors yeah with
actors you know what I mean like that
was what he defended himself on Meghan
Fox made that comment and from the
critics that don't like the movie I
noticed it's like these guys were
obviously Michael Bay haters and did not
like the movie prior to seeing oh yeah I
did like about this story was it is like
Michael Bay on Goodfellas because it is
about
that first that lust that you see like
wow everyone has a much more luxurious
life than mine man turning into that
world and then just a crazy descent into
madness 100 then mike then with all the
narration and stuff it's like two
Scorsese like I see guys liking it more
than girls to know for there was there's
one woman in the movie who's like she
does not put a woman in a good life yeah
really of like an obese obnoxious woman
he loves black girl black guys and the
upper Wilson's kind of hot I'm not gonna
lie to you right yeah for sure
keep on saying it get out of my room
cage Mart you then you're Mark Wahlberg
and that makes you the rock like the
most like the rock out of all of us okay
I'm sorry I'm Mark wolves on the Black
gets one in the group thing baby giggle
back yeah but one thing I you know I got
to say about Michael Bay's direction
that I really appreciate on a phone like
this is because there's gonna be that
obvious moment where these guys are
gonna succeed at what they do and then
they're gonna be living in a world full
of debauchery it's all legal and binding
and they're enjoying it
what I liked about it was Michael Bay
doesn't allow you to believe they got
away with it you know what I mean
so that it keeps the tension going it
doesn't that's what I mean he doesn't
seem like he's supporting these guys
like some people are accusing them
because you don't feel like they've
gotten away with it you don't feel like
they succeed it isn't even allowing you
to feel that way when that moment comes
yeah Michael Damon really broke his own
mold by not diving 100% into it's like
okay they got the money now let's show
them like partying with the [ __ ] and
like you know gratuitous like lens
flares shots of the [ __ ] Lambo
driving around it's like any other time
Michael Bay would be doing that like
full [ __ ] force balls out and [ __ ]
jacking off to the goddamn like Maserati
[ __ ] chassis but this time he pulled
back yeah so I want to give him credit
for that there's a very divided audience
here people who don't like these
characters and people who people who
really like these characters and like
what he did and people who really don't
and when you get a movie like that that
challenges audiences I consider that a
success
you said no violence and I meant it when
I said it I swear to God
I cannot kill duly noted look when this
is over we'll all go camping all right
okay so are we thinking what's the
consensus here what is consensus Michael
Bay's first good movie in a long time is
the reason to see Payton game Michael
Bay's first good movie in a long time is
the reason to see pain in game and the
cast to Sherry's consensus yeah there
are a surprising amount of reasons to
see painting yeah there are a surprising
amount of reasons to see pain and game
it just goes to show you man if you give
Michael Bay a pretty good script some
good actors he can share out something
pretty darn good and I dug it consensus
painting game is the reason Michael Bay
was made the reason Michael Bay was made
I don't at the end of the day believe
that Michael Bay in and of himself is a
great filmmaker I just think that he
happened to find a project that suited
what he does anyways alright guys thanks
for checking out the show why don't you
go ahead scroll to that comment box
below and tell us your reasons to see or
not to see pain and gain and if you want
to see more episodes of reasons to see
click this link right here and if you
want to see my straight to the point
review of pain and game exceptionally
shorter review click on the link right
here and if you guys want to get updated
every time a new reviewer video is out
subscribe click on Erin man it's not
whey protein it's it's this is some way
the whole standard whey variety it's
leftover cocaine from the rock this will
bring us a sponsorship from whey protein
right yeah optimum nutrition totes wants
the spot
being great if they have like a whey
protein thing but it was just filled
with a bunch of cocaine and that's what
the rock was using a bulk up and
actually he was just doing coke shakes
okay probably don't probably kill you
but he was on he was working out a lot
lizards pitch this painting game too
there's so many more places for these
characters to go besides prison
you